Tim Ferriss: Soman, good sir.
Soman Chainani: Thanks for having
me here. This is going to be fun.
Tim Ferriss: So nice to see you.
And it's hard to believe this is, I think,
our first episode in person.
Soman Chainani: Yeah,
which I think makes it more real, somehow.
Tim Ferriss: Makes it more real. Definitely
makes it more colorful. But before we
get to the colorful, Soman Chainani,
for those who don't know, who are you?
Soman Chainani: I think of myself as a
specialist in the teenage mind, and I access
that by being an author of young adult fantasy,
using everything I can about connecting to young
people and lovers of fantasy through novels. So
that's what I've been doing for the last 10 years.
Tim Ferriss: And for people who might want to
dig into that further, any works
you might suggest they start with,
or check out, website, anything like that?
Soman Chainani: I wrote a series called The
School for Good and Evil for 10 years. There's six
books in the series, and Netflix made a movie out
of it that came out last year. And then another
book a little bit for older audiences is called
Beats and Beauty, which is going to be a TV show
sometime soon. So those are my two main things.
Tim Ferriss: And we'll link to everything in
the show notes for folks. I have explored your
writing, and we're looking at some of your
writing, your handwriting on cards of various
colors. We have orange neatly lined up in one
row, yellow, and then purple. And this alludes to,
in a sense, your beautiful pursuit of symmetry
and color and also the format of the show.
So I had sent you a note about this fun
experimental format, which is five things
you're excited about, five things you've changed
your mind about, and then five things that are
absurd that you still do, or do, and tweak that
a little bit, and we'll see if we get to all of
them. The point is really just to provide a launch
pad for conversation, but I was thinking in terms
of naming, Five of Three is not terribly catchy,
but Four by Four, like the piece of wood, is kind
of catchy. So we could do four of each of these
and then add four people you are interested in —
Soman Chainani: It works for me.
Tim Ferriss: — or following, or who people should
know more about. And you so delightfully put out
these cards and offered me dealer's choice. And
there are many things we could go to here.
Give people some foreshadowing. There's
"Intermittent pop star," "Cross-collar dating,"
"Your bull might be gay," "NYC L.A.," but we're
not going to start there. We are going to
start with "Follow the flow," speaking of
catchy. So what does "Follow the flow" mean?
Soman Chainani: It's interesting because every
time I've decided to write a novel, like what
my next book is going to be, and I telegraph
this to my agent and my publisher for a couple
of years. When it comes time to write that book,
I'll start it, but it never ends up being the
book I write next, ever. And what I realized
is that your conscious mind can't actually solve
problems. It can execute, it can deliver on the
promise of something, but what actually is going
to be the next creative force in your life, the
next big decision, has to come to you naturally.
So it's this idea of the decision coming to you
rather than you making it. And I think, especially
in creative work, where it's so important.
Obviously I'm going to be working two or three
years on a novel. My brain will not let me work on
something unless it decides it. So I've realized
more and more as time goes on that I am just the
manager. I'm the manager of the creativity. I'm
not the actual creator. The elves are the creator.
They're going to tell me what to do. They're going
to be the ones who tell you what the next book's
going to be. They're the ones who are going to
come up with the chapter titles. They're going
to do everything. I just have to show up.
Tim Ferriss: I have so many follow-ups.
May I dive in?
Soman Chainani: Please.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So
I aspire to embrace this.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I am like an over-caffeinated Swiss
manufacturing plant manager with OCD and various
other monkish tendencies. So I think the manager
is kind of running the asylum, so to speak —
Soman Chainani: Yes, yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: — on my side. And that doesn't
mean I don't have moments of inspiration,
but I justify this by having a schedule, [foreign
language], and I kick out a certain amount over a
certain period of time, whatever it might be. That
is a superpower that is also a super weakness,
in excess. Now on the opposite side of the
spectrum, I saw this post on social media,
be careful, folks. It's a jungle out there, but I
did see a post that I thought was kind of funny.
And we're sitting here in Austin, there's a lot of
conspirituality here, a lot of aspiring shamanist
Earth goddesses running amok, and their male
equivalents. And this post on social said, "A
woman who lives in the moment finds out that that
moment is connected to all other moments." And it
was like this sad, fake Onion article about not
being able to plan a life. You clearly ship in the
sense that you publish books, you are very engaged
with the world. You're not just a ship without a
sail, without a rudder, getting blown everywhere,
to and fro. So how do you precipitate, or think
about inviting, the muse? Does that make sense?
Soman Chainani: Yeah, 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: Because you could
just be waiting for 10, 20 years.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. I think what ends up
happening is that I know what my conscious mind
can do. So for instance, every publisher wants me
to write a fairy tale fantasy next, because School
for Good and Evil was my first. It was abnormally
successful. Therefore, I will get paid infinite
amount of money, have infinite amount of resources
to write a fairy tale fantasy. I had a fairy tale
fantasy that I wanted to do. I wanted to reinvent
Neverland, sort of do a Game of Thrones version
of Neverland. I had the whole thing planned out.
My conscious brain mapped out, over the course
of a year and a half, an entire world while I
was writing School for Good and Evil. I would
doodle it in notebooks. I had everything.
And then when it came time to write it,
I wrote the first two chapters, went to sleep, and
the next day was like, "This is not my next book."
And it came from just this feeling of which the
only way I can describe it is there was part of
me that is like, "We are not going to spend
two years following the wrong impulse," which
the wrong impulse was money, easy route, the
easy route. And instead, this other idea that
I've been noodling around and been trying to
give away to people for the last five years,
I had told everyone this idea being like, "Someone
should do this idea. This idea is super important.
Someone should do this. It's not me. I can't do
this. This is too hard." I just woke up and was
like, "Okay, you know what? That idea, let's try
writing it as a short story instead because that
idea is so important, and no one's done it, and
everyone says it can't be done or whatever." So
I start working on it, give it to my agent.
Tim Ferriss: Can you mention the idea,
or is it still under wraps?
Soman Chainani: Not yet. Soon,
because we're about to take it out. But meanwhile,
my poor agent, he knows that whatever I say,
the next thing's going to be, "It's not
going to be the next thing." So I tell him,
"I'm just going to try this idea as a
short story," because we've sold short
stories before. He's like, "Okay." While
he comes up with his next fairy tale,
he will do his short story. Do the short story.
Tim Ferriss: Must appease the talent. Fine,
I'll get you your green M&Ms.
Soman Chainani: He's just waiting
for me to come back with Neverland, Wonderland,
he doesn't care what it is, happily ever after,
princess, princesses. So I start working on
this short story, and I start getting into it,
and then I feel that feeling. It's what
I felt with School for Good and Evil,
which is I don't care who reads this, I don't
care what happens to this. This is mine. No
one's taking it away from me. I am doing this at
the expense of all other things. I don't care.
Tim Ferriss: What are the symptoms of that?
Is it that you wake up earlier than normal
and that's the first thing you want to
do? Is it that — I'm making things up,
of course. Is it a giddy feeling that just
doesn't occur normally in other circumstances?
What is the signature of that feeling?
Soman Chainani: It's more like you feel like a
cult leader. You're like, "This is the thing."
Tim Ferriss: This is the true way.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, this is now my church.
People are going to join. I just need to write
the thing. It becomes your whole personality.
Tim Ferriss: So is it fair to say it's a degree
of conviction and confidence that
you couldn't analytically justify?
Soman Chainani: No, you can't change — in
fact, it's funny. We took it to my current
publisher, not even 10 pages of it and just the
general thing of the ideas. And I've been with
them for 10 years writing fairy tales, and they
were like, the idea of me moving into a different
age bracket, and this is not fairy tales at
all. This is far from it as possible. They
wouldn't even entertain the idea, wouldn't even
go there. And it still did nothing to shake me
whatsoever. I was just like, "Oh," and it's funny
because my parents, my agent, everyone's like,
"What are you..." Clearly your second thing should
be to capitalize on that, and nothing in my body
will let me do it. So I have been happy as a clam
working on this other thing, and I realized that
it comes down to what you want your life to be.
And mine is not getting diminishing returns on the
ghost of a past work, even for a lot of money.
Tim Ferriss: I remember, I believe it was BJ
Novak, who's written a million things,
very talented, very funny comedian also,
said whenever he says to himself, "But the money
is so good," that's a flag. And I'm paraphrasing
here, but in this particular case, so I'm
going to prod a little bit, you can refuse,
but is it fiction? Nonfiction?
Soman Chainani: It's fiction.
Tim Ferriss: It's fiction, okay.
Soman Chainani: It's a fiction that I would
like to happen. So it's a predictive fiction.
And it's so funny because when we announce it,
which will be soon enough, all these things that
we're going to talk about today, it's all there.
Tim Ferriss: So it's like The Usual Suspects
with "Kobayashi" on the cup. Wait a minute.
Soman Chainani: Everything, it's all
going to make sense when we're done.
Tim Ferriss: I cannot wait to see how
"Your bull might be gay" fits into
this. All right, so it seems like "Follow the
flow" has been checked. Now, that seems to,
this is fun. I might have people do this, although
I'm sure a lot will not be as enthused as — you
have very nice handwriting, too. So we've pulled
one of the orange cards. Does this purple "Give
stories away" tie back —
Soman Chainani: It does.
Tim Ferriss: — to what you were saying?
Soman Chainani: It's the idea of,
I get a lot of big ideas, and I will not write a
book until I've had the idea for at least three
years. It has to stay with me for three years
because it's going to take me that long to write,
promote, take it out, and I need to be
sure that it's not going to suddenly be a
short-term relationship. And it feels also like
it's timeless then. If it lasts three years,
it's made it through most of a presidential
administration. It's made it through all the
ups and downs. I feel like it's going to last.
And so first thing I do when I get a big
idea that I'm really excited about is I
start to tell everybody. I just am like,
"Someone should do this." I tell all my
writer friends, I tell anybody. I'm just
like, oh, sometimes I'll just have meetings
with Hollywood companies about, I don't know,
adapting other work or stuff like that. I'm
doing it really to just be like, "Someone
should do this idea," and sometimes it gets
picked up, and they'll give it to someone else,
or there's many times where I've had ideas or
something and someone has done that version of it.
But if no one takes it, then
after a few years, sometimes
it's so strong that that's when I do it, so —
Tim Ferriss: I do know of one other person in
my life, friend named Kevin Kelly, I don't know
if you know this name, older gent, has an amazing
Amish-style beard, despite the fact that he is an
incredibly accurate futurist. He's more than that,
but he's very good at predicting trends and
upcoming development. He tries to give away all of
his ideas, and I don't want to speak for him, but
in a sense, it's in the hopes that other people
will do the work of implementing those ideas.
Soman Chainani: It's totally selfish. It's not
a generous thing at all. It's, "This would
be great. Do it for my entertainment so I
can see it realized," because there's only
so many things I'm going to be able to do.
I am jealous of songwriters who, if they have
a great idea, they make their one song. You
know what I mean? This is, every time I
have a big idea, it's a couple of years.
Tim Ferriss: Now this might seem like a silly
question, but how do you distinguish between ideas
that people won't pick up because they're bad
ideas versus ideas people won't pick up because,
for whatever reason, you are uniquely suited to
looking through the prism and seeing something
they don't see? You get what I mean? If you were
like, "I'm going to start a waste management
company in Tuscaloosa," and people are like,
"I'm not going to do that," that is fundamentally
different from what you're describing.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, I always say the test is,
can someone else do it? So that's when I have the
idea. I'm always like, "Sure, someone else can do
this." But then, if they don't and time goes on,
and this is what happened with this idea because
when I first had it a few years ago, I thought,
"I don't know how to do that. It's too hard.
It's just not in my wheelhouse." And as the years
went by, little by little, I started to be like,
"Well, what if I could do this? And this plays
to my strengths, and move this around. I start
to see the..." Then all of a sudden, you realize
you're ready. You know what I mean? So I think
it's about can you do it? Like School for Good
and Evil came out at a time where that year,
there were eight other books about magic schools
because it had been 10 years since Harry Potter,
and it felt like 10 years later, the
floodgates opened and everyone was like,
now all the narcissists who think they can compete
with J.K. Rowling are ready to show their wares.
And agent was frantic, the publisher was nervous,
everyone was nervous, because there were much
bigger books. I think Chris Colfer, who was on
Glee, had one. And Mattel was putting one out
called Ever After High, which was, Ever After
High, School for Good and Evil, they were so
similar, and I was never worried because I'm like,
mine is so weird. It's so strange. It's just so
uniquely me. I just knew there wasn't going to
be, I'm like maybe mine will be a total flop,
but whoever reads it will never compare it to
any of those others, and that I was confident
in. I just know that I just have a very strange
way of storytelling because it's just mine. I
don't know how to follow other people's things.
Tim Ferriss: So number one, we'll catch up over
dinner about this, but I am actually in a
very similar position right now. I have a
writing project, my first book in six
to seven years. I can't talk about it
right now. And I tried to fucking give it away
forever, and it didn't work, it didn't work,
it didn't work. And then, a few close friends
who knew about it kept asking me for it,
who I thought were going to help me do it. And
I was like, fuck, okay, let me take another look
at it. And then I took another look at it, and I
was like, oh, I think I'm ready. I wasn't ready.
Soman Chainani: That's it. You weren't ready.
Tim Ferriss: I wasn't ready, but now I
looked at it and I was like, oh, I think I'm
ready. And that's uncanny, first of all. And oh,
God, I can't wait until dinner. Anyway, so
there's that. Second thing that what you said
reminded me of is there's a very famous Brazilian
jiu-jitsu competitor named Marcelo Garcia. And
last I checked, he's nine-time, maybe 10-time
world champion. And for at least, I would say,
the better part of a decade, and the sport
has evolved a lot, so things may have changed,
but he was considered the greatest of all
time. And that was uncontroversial. He was
so successful, he was so uniquely himself.
Some techniques he pioneered, and he would
record a lot of his training footage and practice
footage, sparring footage, even when he was six
months away from the world championships. And
he would make it available online. And people
found this mystifying because that is very
rarely done. And the most common response was,
"Why would you do that? It allows your competitors
to prepare for you." And his response, and I'm
paraphrasing, but it's pretty close because my
friend co-founded a jiu-jitsu school with him,
so I got to spend some time around him, was, "This
is my game. If someone wants to step into my game,
then I am the best suited…"
Soman Chainani: So interesting.
Tim Ferriss: "...to win my game." Now there are
a million different ways that could be confusing,
but I found it odd enough that I sat with it. And
in a sense, it's like by giving away your ideas,
you're using it selfishly, number one, to get
more ideas than you could shoulder into the world,
hopefully, if people pick it up. And then
secondly, you are filtering to what is uniquely
your own, where you have this differentiator,
which is also, not to view anything zero sum,
but a huge competitive advantage.
Soman Chainani: Well, the other thing
that was interesting that helped me the most,
and I wish this on every young writer, anytime I
did something for money, or something that wasn't
100 percent like me, that someone hired me to do,
they all fell apart, without fail. None of it ever
came out. So there's not a single thing out there
in the world by me that was a mercenary job. I
took them in my 20s and 30s. They never made it
there. So I think that was sort of the world kind
of telling — because it happened so many times,
at least 10 times. So after that I just learned,
we're not doing this, even to the point of,
I'll get in trouble for talking about this
story, but who cares? DC Comics hired me to
do a short story for them. And everyone in
my life, every male thought, "Forget what
you've done before. This 20-page thing you're
doing for DC Comics means you've arrived."
And I'm like, "Okay, thanks." And so I go through
the process with them. It's a nightmare because
they're making changes to the character. They're
just moving things around because it's the DC
machine or whatever. And I spend six months on
it, obviously doing my own work at the same time,
but going through it. The whole time I'm
thinking, "This is getting further and
further away from me," to the point of,
okay, I'll take the check and whatever.
And then at the last second, it all fizzled. The
editorial didn't approve of this, and moved this,
and the whole thing just went poof as it was
about to print. The art was already done,
everything. I remember my poor beleaguered agent
was like, "What?" And I was like, "Thank God."
That went through the whole, it kept the theme,
that narrative in my life, complete because had
that been published, it would've been the first
time. And the fact that it went up completely
in smoke on its own accord was, I think, the
universe being like, "You are on a frequency
and we will help you when you get off it." So
as long as back to follow the flow, as long as
I follow that flow, everything's going to be okay.
Tim Ferriss: So "Follow the flow," "Give stories
away." At first glance, it might seem like some
kind of poetic artist affect, but it's intensely
practical, intensely practical. And so what I'm
going to do, just because this is a new game that
we're playing, and I want to take a photograph
from the top when we're done with this of these
cards, I'm going to turn this over.
Soman Chainani: Perfect.
Tim Ferriss: So I feel like we should go to a
different category just for the fun of it. You
know what? I feel like I'm burying the lede. So
"Your bull might be gay," what's the story here?
It's in quotation marks, which makes it stand out.
Soman Chainani: I told you when when we started,
I told you that none of these are euphemisms,
right? None of these are. So this is the story.
So I lived in New York for 22 years. I now
live in St. Louis. I moved there for love,
for my partner, who is a farmer and
lives on a goat and cattle farm of
his own. And I go there every weekend
and spend three or four days there. And
so I'm that annoying person who drops in every
weekend and has thoughts about what he's been
working on all week. So anyway, he's go, I think —
Tim Ferriss: The helicopter farmer from the city.
Soman Chainani: Who's never been anywhere
near a farm, who has thoughts all the time.
Tim Ferriss: Know what you should really do?
Soman Chainani: Which he finds very amusing.
So he's got over 100 cattle, and he's got these
60 heifers every year that get impregnated by one
bull. So there's one bull that does all the
work. And he keeps a bull for, in this case,
he had a bull for four years. And this bull, when
I saw it, I was like, oh, man. Where he walks,
the ground shakes, the females part, they
bow their head. It's like The Lion King,
right? His balls are the size of coconuts. What
men in Austin, the patriarchy they aspire to here,
that religion that I see men here go for, is that
bull. They need to spend time with that bull,
and everything will be fine.
Tim Ferriss: They need bronze
statues of this bull.
Soman Chainani: And so,
when I was with [redacted], he was like, "The
problem is this bull has been here for four
years," meaning he's now impregnated not just
the heifers, but their daughters, their sisters,
their granddaughters. The cows don't care. So at
some point you need to get a new bull. So he goes
and gets this new bull that he's very excited
about, and he comes and brings the bull. And
the first thing the bull does when it comes to the
farm is it nuzzles up to me and is really nice to
me. And it's just this very sweet bull. And over
the next few weeks, every time I see the bull,
he's off picking flowers, or hanging out with this
little orphaned male calf and licking him. And the
females are literally just staring at him because
they're all in heat and nothing's happening. And
I said, "Your bull might be gay." He's like, and
this is where it gets interesting because this —
Tim Ferriss: This is where it gets interesting.
Soman Chainani: — is where he's like,
"That's impossible." He's like, "We tested its
sperm. It's very healthy. It's a good bull."
And the chance of a bull being gay and not
impregnating these 60 females is, he's like,
"It's maybe like 0.05 percent." And I'm like,
in my head, all I'm thinking about is worst case
scenario because if that bull is gay, that means
he not only doesn't get these 60 females pregnant,
he loses a season. He loses all the money from
the calves that's coming in. It's literally a
catastrophic thing that can happen to him.
And I realize that people entertain worst
case scenarios differently. His is, statistically,
this isn't happening, so therefore I'm not going
to prepare for it. I'm not going to spend a
dollar preparing for that worst case scenario
because statistically, it doesn't make sense. All
I care about in life is the worst case scenario.
So to me, the moment I'm like, "That bull is
gay," all I'm doing is finding all the evidence
that it's gay and being like, "Here's the action
plan for the gay bull. We are getting every female
pregnancy tested. You're having the vet come
out, you're checking this sperm again, you're
doing this, you're bringing out that fancy machine
that triggers them." I'm spending, in my head, I'm
getting him to spend thousands of dollars on this
gay bull to make sure it still gets them pregnant,
like artificial insemination, everything.
And I realized it's just a different way
that we operate. My entire life, and I
told my assistant this on day one, I said,
"Your job is to always think of the worst case
scenario and insure against it. That's your only
job. Every day, what's the worst thing that
can happen? And make sure it doesn't happen."
And [redacted] doesn't think that way because
he says that costs money. It just does. You
spend too much money on things that statistically
shouldn't happen. And I thought there's something
profound in that. So "Your bull might be gay"
has become the kind of flag-waving motto on the
farm because it turns out the bull was not gay —
It secretly got them all pregnant while we weren't
watching. That's the funny part. So he was right.
And therefore, he thinks it validates him. But to
me, I think I get calmer and more at peace when
that worst case scenario is protected against.
Tim Ferriss: So if this is a shorthand, where your
partner, when you're catastrophizing, can say,
"Soman, this may be a your-bull-might-be-gay
scenario," are you finding that you can use
that experience to recalibrate a little bit? Do
you need an external source, like your partner,
to be like, pat you on the side like a
sort of overexcited horse, and be like,
"Everything's going to be okay?"
Soman Chainani: I think it's okay.
Tim Ferriss: Because you and I are very similar in
this way. I haven't had the gay bull experience,
or the thought-to-be-gay bull experience, but you
and I have bonded over this worst case scenario,
catastrophizing, which clearly if it had no
utility, we wouldn't use it, but in excess,
sort of becomes its opposite,
right? It's a helpful tool, and
then it becomes a hindrance at a certain point.
Soman Chainani: But see, I cheat because I offload
it to my assistant. That's his job. I literally am
like, "You are the worst case scenario person." So
he's in charge of insuring against those things.
And now that he's been with me a while, in a way,
that's become his thing. And he's even more kind
of obsessive about predicting all those things,
and it's what makes him so amazing, as he's risen
in the ranks. And so, in a way, I'm a little lucky
that I'm not the one staying awake at night —
Tim Ferriss: Outsource some of your worrying.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. I think having
a partner who has the opposite viewpoint,
if I was with someone who also had the worst
case scenario, dangerous, it's dangerous,
then you're just, who's going to screw
in the light bulb when you're too busy
worrying about, insuring against all the other
things that are never going to happen. At some
point, someone has to take care of the basics.
Tim Ferriss: The counterbalance.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, I think counterbalance.
Tim Ferriss: The outsourcing your worry to your
assistant, your EA, makes me think of this
chapter, which was an excerpt that I had
in my very first book, from A.J. Jacobs. And I
think it was literally called Outsourcing Your
Life from originally Esquire, I want to say. And
at one point, he was trying to see how much he
could give his virtual assistant at that point
in India. And at one point he realized — A.J.
is amazing. He's written a lot of great books. My
favorite's probably The Year of Living Biblically,
but he's written a lot of great books.
And he, at one point, was really worried about
something, and he just decided as an experiment
to see if he could ask his assistant to worry on
his behalf if that would make him feel better. No
real solution, no fixing anything. He's just like,
"Would you mind worrying about this on
my behalf?" And, I mean, he's a humorist,
right, so he does a lot of funny stuff, but
he actually found it therapeutically valuable.
Soman Chainani: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Just the broad strokes
instruction, "Could you worry about this
so I know someone's worrying about it?
Like I realize it's not productive, but
could you worry about it on my behalf?"
Soman Chainani: This will come back. This will
come back up. Well, it's also funny because I
think it's uniquely suited to the young, to
be able to have that mindset. And I told him,
I said, "If you can master this thing of thinking
about the worst case scenarios and everything,
that's what I did when I was young and
working as an assistant. You're going
to be like a mega mogul one day. You just
will, because that's part of your thinking
in a way that it isn't for other people.”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. The Andy Grove,
Only the Paranoid Survive kind of thing. Only the
paranoid stay up at night staring at the ceiling,
too, but there is that. So question about the
assistant. What other instructions have you found,
or principles make for training
an excellent assistant? And I'm
asking because I'm in the process right now of
actually training some new folks on my team. So
this is very top of mind for me.
Soman Chainani: I think, to me,
the most important thing, especially when you
find someone who just has so much talent and
capability, like Jun has, is that I don't
give tasks. I give massive projects that
are extraordinarily difficult.
Tim Ferriss: What would be
an example, if you don't mind?
Soman Chainani: An example would
be like in the case of DC. I was like, "I
don't know anything about DC Comics. What am
I writing about? What am I going to do?"
Tim Ferriss: "What am I writing about?"
Soman Chainani: Yeah, "What am I doing?" Because
in this case it's a general world that I'm
just — I don't know anything.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you had
to work with their characters?
Soman Chainani: Their characters.
It's not an original, it's working with their
characters. So that's where it all went wrong.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, you were —
Soman Chainani: I was headed already.
Tim Ferriss: You were already —
Soman Chainani: In trouble. So in that case,
I was like, "It's not that I'm looking for a
storyline, I'm just looking for, all right,
knowing what I'm interested in, give me some
characters from there that are interesting."
Tim Ferriss: Good. All right. All right.
Soman Chainani: "Give me a world that's
interesting. Show me some things in DC that…" and
so rather than it being like, "Make me a list of
this," or something very task-oriented, it'll just
be like, "Show me something." And that's kind of
like the bigger thing. And then giving freedom for
him to structure it, him to figure out how he's
going to present it, him to have investment in it.
The same thing when we did Beasts and Beauty. We
were presenting it to the studios to
get a buyer for the TV series. I said,
"How do we present this? How do we present the
book? Come up with whatever you think's the best
way." And ultimately he designed this amazing
presentation, and therefore when we sell it,
it's easy for me to go to the studio and say,
"Jun has to be a producer on it," because he
was the one who led the whole presentation. So
it's that sort of thing. It's like I give very,
once in a while, give very few task-oriented
things and more like, "Worry about this for me."
Tim Ferriss: All right, I'm going to ask very —
maybe boring, maybe interesting. We'll see. But
certainly mundane, practical questions.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Do you do all your own
inbox management or do you have —
Soman Chainani: Yeah, I do all that stuff.
Tim Ferriss: You do all your inbox stuff?
Soman Chainani: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Now, is that a manageable inbound
volume? You've just figured out policies and maybe
how to hide yourself effectively so that you don't
get an inordinate amount of stuff?
Soman Chainani: Yeah. I think it's,
if it's scheduling, if it's — I'll
pass all that stuff on to him.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So he will do —
Soman Chainani: Yes, yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: He's keeping
the trains running on time.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. 100 percent.
100 percent. But I still manage my own email
inbox. I just am sorting stuff over there.
Tim Ferriss: What kind of stuff would you
say buckets-wise? What kind of stuff
does he handle? Scheduling management?
Soman Chainani: Scheduling, school visits,
anything that involves a calendar date. And
also negotiating. I get asked to speak constantly,
whether it's adults looking for a creative spark
at a corporation, or whether it's schools, or
whether it's a book festival. You've been through
this. Many, many speaking engagements.
Tim Ferriss: You are a far better
speaker and presenter than I am.
Soman Chainani: I don't know. You know
what? If they're teenagers, I feel completely at
home. Adults, sometimes I'm like, "Are your minds
frozen? Is there anything I can do?"
Tim Ferriss: "To chip away at the
calcification on your brains?"
Soman Chainani: Sometimes I feel
that way. So his job is to figure out somehow
subliminally, without making a mess of it,
is do they have a budget? It's all that stuff.
Tim Ferriss: And you have rules or at least
guidelines in place where you're like,
"Hey, this is the lowest hurdle," et cetera.
Soman Chainani: Yes, yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Your bull might be gay.
Well, let's hop to the secret card,
which was a last-minute addition.
And we can chat about any person you
think people should pay attention to
or that you're simply paying attention to.
Soman Chainani: Have you heard of this guy
named Christopher Marley?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Soman Chainani: He is an artist, but his
canvas only works with preserved animals
from strange parts of the Earth.
Tim Ferriss: Tell me more.
Soman Chainani: He's almost like Indiana Jones.
He works with remote tribes in the Amazon. He'll
just go all over the Earth to find animals we've
never seen before, and then makes art out of them.
Tim Ferriss: Christopher Marley?
Soman Chainani: Christopher Marley. And so
I have all of his books, and I saw an exhibition
of his in person, and it was the most inspiring,
beautiful thing I have ever seen.
Tim Ferriss: That's a strong statement.
Soman Chainani: It is.
Tim Ferriss: And that's coming from someone who's
exposed to art. You're exposed to all that art.
Soman Chainani: Art is my life, yeah, but this
is because they're real animals. And so the idea
of, I spend my life creating fantasies. And then
to see that the real world has more fantastical
things than you'll ever see. And he has so many
great ones where you'll see, he'll just make art
out of maybe a thousand butterflies that he's
collected. But the colors of the butterflies,
you've never seen stuff like this before.
It's almost like when you think of the deep sea
fish that you've never seen before. He's finding
this up on land. So the beetles, the snakes,
the this. But then he has this additional talent
of making the most spectacular art out of it
so that it almost looks — if they were fake,
it would still be equally impressive. So the fact
that he's going there, making these relationships,
getting animals that — convincing these tribes
to hold onto animals that they find for him.
The whole thing's insane. And the fact that this
guy isn't the most famous person in the world,
to me, is shocking.
Tim Ferriss: How did
you come across Christopher Marley?
Soman Chainani: I was in North Carolina
taking — we were on a family reunion trip and
we went to the museum with my niece and nephew,
who were teenagers. And that was the little fun
thing. And then I bought all his books, I followed
him on Instagram, and I just think it's the most —
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. All right.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. As soon as you start looking
at his art, you're going to be like — and also he
has a crazy story, which is, they had a photo
of him up on the wall. And I was like, "That's
him?" He was a supermodel. He was a supermodel,
this rugged supermodel who then, I don't know,
used his wealth to then do what he really
wanted to do, which was like be Indiana Jones.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
Soman Chainani: But the talent is insane,
the way he places everything. I almost want
to pause for a second and show you the art.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Yeah, sure. Let me take a look.
Soman Chainani: You have to see it
because once you see it you're going
to be like — hold on. You're going
to want to make him your best friend.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow. Okay.
All right. That's wild.
Soman Chainani: That's just one.
Tim Ferriss: That is wild.
That's wild.
Soman Chainani: If you go back to the grade,
you'll just see tons of them.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah. Okay. So this is
@christophermarleystudio, spelled like Bob Marley.
Christophermarleystudio. Almost 60,000 followers.
Soman Chainani: It should be 60 million.
Tim Ferriss: "All vertebrates are reclaimed
specimens. None are killed for art." That was
going to be one of my questions. Okay, yes. All
right. All right. This is going to be a thing.
And you're right. If there were a game of match,
match the face to this other profession on the
other side in column B, this is not to detract
from his work, but I would be like, "Yeah, no."
Soman Chainani: No.
Tim Ferriss: No way. Maybe he's doing
jeans commercials, maybe he's doing car
commercials. But his artwork is incredible. Okay,
we will definitely link to that. Check it out,
folks @christophermarleystudio. All right,
check, check. My next follow on Instagram.
see. I thought it was conch and then I was
like, "Oh, wait a second. That's an A."
Soman Chainani: Oh, that's an A. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Coach Alpha.
Soman Chainani: Coach Alpha.
Tim Ferriss: What or who is Coach Alpha?
Soman Chainani: Okay. I realized that I can
only do two jobs in my life. There's only two
things I'm good at and there's only one thing
I would like to do as much as I like writing,
and that is I feel like — and it's a
job that should exist, and it doesn't.
Generation Alpha, which is teenagers of today —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I didn't know that was a thing.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. So after —
Tim Ferriss: We've gone back to A.
Soman Chainani: Yes, so after Gen Z is Generation
Alpha, and that's like who are teenagers now.
They're growing up in an impossible situation
with everything that's happening with the world
and the phones getting more addict — it's just
impossible. And when I was a tutor, I was a tutor
for 10 years, and what I loved the most was when
— because I could tutor every subject. I was such
a nerd in school that I just really could tutor
any subject. And I loved it when a parent just
outsourced their entire child's home life to me.
But I loved it because I could get to the bottom
of what made them tick and what was important, and
starting to really not just help them with school
but get them on a better track, like out of their
phone, and stop worrying about what everybody else
wanted them to be, including their parents,
and more focusing on who they actually were.
The mental health crisis that's affecting almost
all teenagers is this sort of existential dread.
And so I would've loved to, if I hadn't become
a writer, and I still feel like this is going
to be part of my life somehow, is I would love
to be the Mary Poppins who can go into a house
and just be like, "Let's get this on track." I'll
give you an example in a way that parents can't.
One kid I met was getting off track because he was
drinking a lot and getting in trouble and all that
sort of stuff. And I noticed that every time I
saw him, he was talking about going out, partying,
and at the end of the night having wrestling
matches with all his friends and just getting
into these physical fights with people. And he
was always beating up on his younger brothers.
Every time I saw him they were just always
physical with this thing. And one day we're
trying to solve all the other stuff —
Tim Ferriss: The academic stuff.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, just everything else.
And I thought to myself — actually I said to
him. I said — and his whole goal in life was to be
popular and party and all that stuff. And I said,
"I don't know if partying is your goal in reality.
I feel like your real goal is that you want to
fight. That's what you actually want to do." What
you really want to do is not drink and hang out
with your friends. It's you want to drink so you
can beat them up at the end of the night and get
into these aggro — every night ended in aggro.
And I researched. I said, "There's a UFC gym like
four minutes from your house. Go take a class."
16 year old, go take a class. Takes a class,
loves it. Is now there three, four times a week,
having the time of his life. Drinking went way
down. Everything all got back on track. Got a
job to fund the UFC thing thing. Everything's
fine. No more beating up the brothers. He
didn't need to. He can beat up anyone —
Tim Ferriss: Just needed an outlet.
Soman Chainani: Just needed an outlet.
But what parent's going to say, "Go fight
after school." It's just, they're not going
to do it. And so it's stuff like that where I
just feel like sometimes kids need to be seen
for who they are. And in order for us to get
out of this crisis, I think people are like,
"Oh, mental health crisis, all these things."
I feel like there needs to be a third party,
whether it's even as much as teen groups. I was
just thinking about the fact that on any given
night, if you're an alcoholic or you have a drug
addiction or whatever, you can just go to an AA
meeting and you can have that group experience.
And I felt like, why isn't there that for
teenagers? This idea that you can just go to
a space and meet other teenagers on a given
night and have that kind of place to talk to or
experience. And yes, you can do it online. But I
just think the more you get into your phone,
the further you often get away from actually
who you are and real connection. So I don't
know. I have no formal thoughts on how this
should happen. I do miss that part of my old job,
which was going into the house and helping kids.
Tim Ferriss: Footnote for people who may
have missed our earlier conversations:
well into your writing career, correct me if
I'm wrong, fact check, please, you held onto
your tutoring because it gave you a safety net
but also, I guess, the psychological reassurance
of knowing that you didn't have to white-knuckle,
desperately make the first buck that came your way
through the writing. Is that a fair description?
We don't have to spend too much time on it.
Soman Chainani: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: But it's important
as an example to me because a lot of creatives who
do really well do not burn the ships behind them.
They do not block all the exits. They actually
have some type of backup in the form that you did.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent, because also it meant
that I could take all the risks in my writing. So
even now I know I can do other jobs. I could go
back to tutoring, I could teach at a university,
I could work with kids and teenagers in some
way. So I'm happy to take the risk on this book
instead of chasing the money because there's no
pressure on it. So I think that's the important
thing. I feel like if you're writing with that
desperate white-knuckle, mercenary for money,
it increases the chance that what you're
writing is, you're trying to fit a mold.
Tim Ferriss: So Coach Alpha, is this a public
attempt to give away an idea? Let's just say
you can't get a taker.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Let's just say you don't see it.
Would you ever think of doing — I know this
isn't in person, but would you ever think of
doing a series of talks and then pulling from
that and putting together a course? Making
lectures available for free? Maybe they're
targeted parents, maybe they're targeted kids.
If this for whatever reason doesn't get takers,
this Coach Alpha, because it also requires — it's
not just an idea that can be executed by anyone.
Soman Chainani: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: But to underscore
something you said, the third-party piece is
really important. I can get not anyone but
almost anyone to change behaviors sometimes except
for the people closest to me because, to them,
I'm just Tim, and sometimes you can develop
a selective deafness around the people you're
closest to. So then when you have a third party
who's credible, there's a lot of leverage there.
Soman Chainani: Well, even I was thinking about
teenagers. Let's say you have — and I've told
parents this many times, and most of the time
they didn't listen, but I gave them the secret,
which was, when your kid takes initiative and
does something on their own, like they start
making their bed or they start working out
after school, do not mention it. Don't say,
"It's great you made the bed," or, "That's so cool
that you're working out." Do not. Then it's your
thing. That means every time they're going to
go make the bed, they're now thinking of your
approval and, little by little, it's going to
stop them doing it because it's now become your
thing. Leave it. It's their thing.
Tim Ferriss: How many kids have
you tutored over the years, would you say?
Soman Chainani: Oh, God. At least a few hundred.
Tim Ferriss: A few hundred?
Soman Chainani: Yeah, probably
a few hundred. Well, I miss it, but also I got
the connection through the books. And also what's
funny is I started doing writing camps where
I got hosted by writing camps. And there was
always a curriculum that they wanted us to teach
or whatever, and I would just go in there and do
my own thing. And the first thing I would work on
with each kid is, when you write, you need to know
what your characters want, and you need to know at
the deepest basis level. So let's say a character
wants to play lacrosse. He wants to be a champion
lacrosse player. That's where most people will
stop. But you need to ask, "Well, why does he want
to be a champion lacrosse player? In order to…"
Tim Ferriss: Why does he want to
drink? That's not enough. It's because
he wants to fight at the end of the night.
Soman Chainani: Wants to fight. And why does
he want to fight at the end of the day? You have
to keep going down until you hit a base level. Is
he trying to save his self-esteem? Is he trying
to prove something to his family? Whatever it is.
And then on the second day, after we work on that
with characters, I do that for themselves. So the
teenager, I'm like, "What do you want?" In front
of the class, so there's usually 12 people. And
that's when you start to get somewhere.
Tim Ferriss: Man, I feel like I
could use that exercise now.
Soman Chainani: But that's how,
for college essays — my specialty when I was
tutoring was college essays. I used to go in
there and help them come up with the perfect
essay topic. And all I needed was three days
with them. And I would spend three days asking
that question over and over, and looking at pieces
of their life and us talking about it until we
came up with, what do you want and why do you
want it? And then making the essay from there.
Tim Ferriss: All right, I'll bite. So what's the
next step? Once you go through that exercise,
how do you craft the narrative, the essay? How
do you put it into essay form? Is it describing
really what you want? Is that the topic of the
essay or do you use that as grist for the mill?
Soman Chainani: It becomes the heart of it and
then from there you can start to build everything
out. I'm thinking about an essay where —
Tim Ferriss: Did you start doing
this before you were working on
fiction or did it happen simultaneously?
Soman Chainani: Simultaneously. Because
as I was working on School for
Good and Evil the thing I had —
Tim Ferriss: You had to think about it.
Soman Chainani: And also because I had
come from film school where they drill into
you, what does your character want? Why do
they want it? And I did that every page of that
book, which is why I think it reads quickly,
because you just know what everybody wants
at any given moment. And I realized that I'm
working with these kids and no one knows what
they want. They follow the flow in the wrong
direction because the flow is taking them towards
anxiety and comparison and all the things that
the world — if I spent my life on Instagram and
TikTok, I would die because it's just the wrong
inputs to make me find what I want to do.
Tim Ferriss: Coach Alpha. I love it. All
right. This is needed. This is needed. I was very
fortunate when I was 15, 16 to have a few mentors,
male mentors, figures who, by a hook or crook,
were able to help me correct course in a number
of ways. If I had not had that input, I think
things could have ended, and I do mean ended
in a very terminal way, very differently.
Soman Chainani: We should talk about another
person on my list, then.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Soman Chainani: He just moved to Austin. His name
is Mike Regula R-E-G-U-L-A. He is an ex-Navy SEAL
and he is here starting a company called Course
of Action, which what I want to do for teenagers,
he's doing for men. And it's using basic Navy SEAL
concepts and training to basically get men to,
both individually and in groups, look at their
lives and make proactive change to become more
connected to what they want. So basically it's
every man who feels like they haven't quite found
their way back onto a path or they've lost their
tribe, or anything like that. He's just trying
to find a safe space for men to work on, whether
it's the psychological part, the nutrition part,
the fitness part, the emotional part, and
in groups. And I think it's just so needed,
especially in this world. So I just think
he's someone to look out for. And I think the
website is OneCOA. OneCOA, for Course of Action.
Tim Ferriss: We'll find it and we'll link to it as
well. How did you find Mike or Course of Action?
Soman Chainani: He was introduced to me
through — this is the best story. The boy I was in
love with in high school was this kid named Noah,
who I was obsessed with. And of course
he's now married with children, everything
like that. And everyone knew this story, except
him, and then one day someone finally told him,
"You do realize that someone spent most of his
high school career trying to get your attention?"
And he just was like, "What?" And so then we
connected, became friends, and he's like, "You
have to meet Mike," because, I don't know what it
was. Mike was in New York and he just felt like we
would bond, and we met, and that was that.
Tim Ferriss: That was that.
Soman Chainani: He's just a special person.
And I just feel like — we were talking about
this. The same way I feel about resuscitating
the teenage mind and soul, he feels about men,
because I think he's seen it all,
having been an ex-SEAL, for sure.
Tim Ferriss: Check it out. He's right here, right
here in my hometown, Mike Regula. And this is
actually not the first time I've heard his name.
This rings a bell and I can't place the context.
Soman Chainani: Oh, he's
friends with all your friends.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, there we go. There you go. That's
probably why I've heard his name. All right, does
anything catch your eye that might make for a good
next Scooby Snack, conversationally speaking? We
could go to — you know what? Here, how about this?
Soman Chainani: Oh, that's a good one.
Tim Ferriss: All right, intermittent pop
star. This is in the absurd category.
Soman Chainani: That's in the absurd category
because I should not still be doing this,
but in 2017 I went to this book festival
for the first time in Charleston called
YALLFest, that is like the biggest book
festival for teenagers in the country.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, about 20,000 kids
descend on this thing. Everybody comes there. It's
where new projects are — it's just a big festival
that takes over Charleston. And to get invited,
it means you've officially made it. And all I
ever wanted in my career was to get invited
because your publisher can't pitch you. It's
like one of these Sun Valley companies —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You must be invited.
Soman Chainani: Must be invited. So I finally
get invited. I'm so excited and I go and it's
the best two days of my life. I'm having the
most amazing time. And I go to the final show,
called the SmackDown, which they charge like $12
to get into. It's 3,000 people in Charleston Music
Hall. It's the most beautiful theater. And the
authors participate in this variety show. And I
sit there and watch the worst show I've ever seen
in my life. It is an abomination to make 3,000
people sit through that. I was — at the fact that
I had to participate in some little part of it.
And I remember having this thing, secretly
thinking, I'm going to take over this show and
turn it into my own private pop concert, and it's
going to be amazing, and it's going to be awesome,
and it's going to be like the greatest show on
Earth. I just remember having this thought. It
was just like, "This is my fantasy and it's going
to happen." I grew up idolizing — you know this,
everyone who knows me knows this, but I should
probably say it. I grew up a huge Madonna fan.
That was my pop star growing up. I'm obsessed
with Taylor Swift. I'm obsessed with anyone
who can translate whatever their talent is into
some kind of cool showmanship. And so cut to two
years later, they were like, "No one wants to
host this show. Do you want to host it?" And I
was like — because I'd earned enough cred to
be like, "Okay." I said, "Sure, as long as I
can completely redo it 100 percent my way."
Tim Ferriss: How did they think to come to
you? Had you planted the seed somehow? Were you
like, "Not a bad show. I could do better," on
the way out with a tear in the eye?
Soman Chainani: I think I said,
"This could be better."
Tim Ferriss: Love your feedback.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: "I have a few words."
Soman Chainani: "This could be better."
Tim Ferriss: Got it. So they came to you?
Soman Chainani: Came to me. And then I was like,
"We're going to do the variety show. It's going
to be all new games and it's going to start with
an eight-song, six-costume-change dance number
dedicated to whatever the themes are in YA."
Almost like a version of Billy Crystal's old Oscar
thing, but even more extreme. And so I don't know
what made me do it, but what was interesting is,
while we started working on it, and we got a
choreographer, and I don't know how to dance,
and I started learning these dance steps.
It was that process of training for it,
learning how to dance, learning how to do
choreography, that was so awesome because
it got me out of my head. And I started to fall
in love with this process of designing a show,
designing things, designing themes. It was a new
way of telling a story from beginning to end.
How do you entertain an audience of 3,000 people
for 10 minutes? I fell in love with it and had
the best time, but then I did it — I think I did
it the next year. I've done it three times. And
what I've realized is if I do it every two years
— because it's so much work. It's so much money of
my own, it's so much work, so much time.
Tim Ferriss: Right. In the red column.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. Just throwing
money on fire. But if I do it every two years,
that means the year in between someone else, some
poor soul has to come and try, and it's inevitably
a disaster. So then when I come back, I get —
Tim Ferriss: Herald! The hero returns.
Soman Chainani: Every two years. Julia Roberts'
strategy was brilliant when she was an actress.
The reason she had such longevity is she
always did one movie where she had her hair
red and curly and did a romcom, and then she
would do one when she hacked it off and played
like Frankenstein's maid. Some crazy, indie weird
thing. But because she did it every other movie,
whenever she came back it was like, "Oh,
thank God. She's back to doing Pretty Woman."
And what's been important for me is, it's less
about — I get more than enough attention for
the books and everything. I don't need — it's
not a — sure, it is a narcissistic thing. What
am I saying? This is such a lie. What a lie.
Terrible. But I think what I enjoy more than
the actual performance is the run-up. It's the day
before rehearsals start. I'm always nauseous. I
don't want to do it. I don't want to go through
that whole experience, because it's everything
I'm bad at. There's a Japanese word. Have you
heard Misogi? There's a book about this that —
Tim Ferriss: I'd have to look it up. Yeah.
Soman Chainani: To find happiness. I think
Mike was telling me about this. The Japanese
concept that once a year or once every two
years you have to do something completely out of
your comfort zone that is an extended journey. And
in doing that, you find new reinvigoration for
life. And I think that's mine. Every two years,
to go into this thing where I don't know how
it's going to end, I don't know if it's going to
work because always it's more ambitious and more
interesting. So it's funny because this one was
bigger and crazier, I just did it a couple months
ago, than anything that we'd ever done before.
And at the party I was like, "There's no
way. There's just — I know myself. I can't
top that scale, what we did." And someone
goes, "Well, what are you going to do now?
Are you going to sing?" And I was like,
"Haha." And then I thought, huh, well —
Tim Ferriss: Ding.
Soman Chainani: I doubt
that's what it's going to be. But it's always
like, when you think you can't find what the
next thing is, it's like, what's the next zone of
discomfort? So that's the silly thing I still do,
but I think it's important for me somehow.
I can't really let go of it at this point.
Tim Ferriss: It does something for you.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, how
would your life be different if it were taken
away? If it were just subtracted? How would
your experience the rest of the year be
different? If there's an answer to that.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. It wouldn't be as
fun. There's something so energizing about
the high-stakes nature of a show. And also my
assistant is this amazing dancer and musician,
so he's part of it. I have backup
dancers and he's one of them. So, it's
like he's — we're all on this ride together where
it can end in super embarrassment, because you've
got thousands of people with their phones out.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. There's no, "You had to be
there." There's, "Let me show you what happened."
Soman Chainani: It feels very high stakes and
in the moment. So, where writing
is never in the moment really,
because you are constantly revising. This
is immediate, and I just think it's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: It's also out of
your head, like you mentioned.
Soman Chainani: Yes. Yeah. I always
feel in incredible shape mentally and
physically after six weeks of this stuff. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to force a segue. We'll see
if it's a natural segue, but drugs.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Now, this is in the
yellow, I believe, change your mind —
Soman Chainani: Change your mind.
Tim Ferriss: — about category.
Soman Chainani: So I never did drugs growing up.
I maybe did pot once or twice and found it slowed
me down to the point of I never wanted to do it
again. And just sort of walled that whole thing
off as, I don't know, stuff that other people do.
And then, during COVID, I read The Body Keeps the
Score. And I had struggled with some things for my
entire life in terms of anxiety and just getting
stuck in kind of ruts of feeling. And it was
2021 January where I just remember, talking about
follow the flow, I stood up, went to my computer.
I remember being in Miami at my parents' house,
Googling "Ketamine treatment, New York City."
I knew nothing about ketamine, nothing.
Tim Ferriss: How was it even in your field?
Soman Chainani: I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: It just popped into the head.
Soman Chainani: I don't know. I just remember
going "Ketamine therapy in New York City," calling
up, scheduling the consultation. And a week later,
I'm back in New York going to meet the
doctor. And I was like, "I don't know
if I'm right for this. I don't want anything
that will mess with my creativity." I said,
"The only reason I'm entertaining this idea
is because it's in a doctor's office." I said,
"I would never do drugs on my own because the
fear surrounding that of what could happen and
where it's procured from and all that stuff would
end up infecting the whole experience. And with
a doctor's office, I'm entertaining it."
I said, "But I don't want it to affect my
creativity. I don't want it to..." He's like,
"It's only going to make you more yourself and
more creative." But he goes, "These are the three
things that I think make for a good candidate."
He's like, "Number one, have you felt emotionally
numb for most of your life?" And at that point in
my life, absolutely. I think I was in just
cycles of numbness. Number two was, "Did you
have a volatile childhood where emotions were not
particularly welcome?" And I was like, "Check."
Tim Ferriss: Check.
Soman Chainani: Check. And number three,
he goes, "This one's the most important." He's
like, "Do you know how to have fun?" And I said,
"No." And I cried. I remember crying in the
office. He's like, "Do you know how to have
fun?" And it was the first time anyone had asked
the question in the right way. Because I knew the
idea of fun. I knew that I should be having
fun. I knew how to act like I was having fun,
but I never felt like I was having fun. And he
goes, "You don't drink?" I said, "No." And he
goes — and I meditate. I was that point, four or
five years into meditation. He's like, "You're
going to have a very good response to this."
He just instantly — and so, I started ketamine
treatments. At that time, I think you do six
in 12 days, and then you go back for a booster.
In my case, it's every 10 weeks and I still go.
And it changed my life. I mean, it was like,
I feel like a totally different person because of
those. Because what it did is it woke up parts of
my brain that I did know existed because they
had shut off so early that I didn't know they
were there. And then, all of a sudden I started
to get glimpses of what I could be like. And then,
it became a question of could I hold
onto that? And little by little over —
Some people, I think, get their benefits much
quicker, or they don't get any benefits at
all. I mean, it's so individual. In my case,
it was almost like a practice. It was like,
every 10 weeks, I'd go learn a million
things, work on those things in between,
go back. And it almost became my version of the
deepest therapy. And I think it's become a huge,
just, reason for everything. And I think it's
also allowed me to follow the flow more than ever,
because the whole thing of a ketamine
treatment is it's a sedative. Right? So,
it puts your brain in such a relaxed state that
you have no choice but to follow the flow where
it goes. And the flow usually leads you closer to
the truth. So, I don't know. I think it's — for
someone who was so anti-drugs, it was the biggest
thing that changed my mind about them. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: In those — well, let's see. Just to
establish some basics, with the whatever it was,
let's call it six sessions in 12 days. So, that
loading phase, let's call it, induction phase,
those were IV? Or —
Soman Chainani: IV.
Tim Ferriss: IV.
Soman Chainani: I've never done
the micro-dosing and the nasal spray and all that
sort of stuff because, again, I don't want to do
anything that is me alone. I will always —
Tim Ferriss: That's a great policy.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I just want to
emphasize how good a decision that is. A lot of
friends I know who have embraced more recreational
use have become addicted to ketamine.
Soman Chainani: Oh, I'm sure.
Tim Ferriss: It has that potential. And you're
also, in a sense, a great candidate/profile
because you don't have any history of alcohol use.
Some people who have a history of alcohol abuse
or just use, extensive use, which
certainly if you go to New York City,
and I've spent a lot of time in New York City,
a lot of social life revolves around alcohol.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And many people there
have switched to ketamine, but it's still a
dissociative anesthetic. So, in those uncontrolled
environments, people can find themselves in a
slide that can become very precarious. But in
the clinical setting, I also find ketamine to be
incredibly interesting. There's a lot of research
people can find on PubMed and elsewhere looking
at the rapid antidepressant effects ketamine and
their different types. For people who might be
interested in the potential benefits and risks
and science related to this, I did an episode
with Dr. John Krystal of Yale who did — he was
the primary investigator on a lot of the seminal
work investigating ketamine as antidepressant in
humans and developed some of the early protocols
with his fellow researchers and scientists.
Soman Chainani: Which is tricky because anytime
anybody, I talk to people close to me, they're
like, "Do you recommend it?" I'm like, "No." And
I never recommend it to people. I don't think I've
ever recommended it to anyone because I found
it difficult. It's a journey into the deepest
core of yourself. It's a lot. It's a lot of work.
Tim Ferriss: And the meditation background also
serves you, and I would imagine, in a very big
way in terms of navigating some of these recesses.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What do your boosters
look like? Is that a single session?
Soman Chainani: Single session.
Tim Ferriss: And in those single
sessions, what does the format look like?
Soman Chainani: It's just —
Tim Ferriss: Music? No music?
Soman Chainani: Oh, no music.
Tim Ferriss: Visuals?
Soman Chainani: Nothing. And it's alone. There's
no therapist after. It's just — I do it in silence
and I just follow the flow wherever it takes
me. And it usually takes me on a ride to the
uncomfortable things that I'm not dealing with
then — it's almost like — the way I describe it
is sometimes I feel like what the ketamine's doing
is relaxing your brain, like pathway by pathway.
And whenever it gets somewhere sticky, that's
shut off, where there's a jam, that's where
you're going to have a little moment.
Tim Ferriss: That's when the traffic
helicopters circle the traffic jam.
Soman Chainani: And then you have to — but I just
think it's over time because I've been willing to
sort of do the work and sort of be in there with
it. It's been a huge thing. And it meant that
I never had to take antidepressants. I never
had to take anti-anxiety medication, things that
someone in my profile probably would've needed.
But instead to go three, four times a year and do
these sessions, I think, and it's also — the great
thing about it is it's a short half-life. It's
over so fast. So I think that's what makes it,
has been such a huge contributor for me.
Tim Ferriss: How long would you say
your active session lasts?
Soman Chainani: One hour.
Tim Ferriss: One hour.
Soman Chainani: Exactly one hour. And then,
just the process of it getting out of your system,
you coming back up, all that stuff is probably
another hour and a half. So, by the time you're
in your Uber home, and then you're good to go.
Tim Ferriss: Some interesting applications
to treatment-resistant depression and
chronic pain also.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I did six infusions several years
ago, and I came in without any particular acute
state of anxiety or depression.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So, the people working
there, the staff and technicians and
MDs and so on were a little mystified. And
I therefore didn't have much in terms of
measurable reductions because I wasn't coming
in with something too reduced at that point.
Soman Chainani: Yes. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: But I left and a few weeks later
I realized, "Oh, my God. That mid-back thoracic
pain that I have felt every day for several years,
I have not felt in probably a month."
Soman Chainani: It's amazing because
anything that's coming from a place of stress —
but the thing is, it could return if you don't
deal with that, if you don't deal with that
psychological stress, it might return, but
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For sure. I felt that too. If
I go in with a lot of muscle soreness, I'll come
back out and it's almost like it never happened.
Tim Ferriss: So, for people who want to learn
more, certainly John Krystal, with a K, Krystal,
and Andrew Huberman also recently had an episode
related to all things ketamine —
Soman Chainani: Oh, interesting.
Tim Ferriss: — which I'm sure
involved a lot of due diligence. So,
you can check that out. "The double." This is in
the excited about category. What is the double?
Soman Chainani: Super excited about.
I've been thinking about this one a lot,
which is there's so much work on your shadow
self in psychology. It's always like, "Oh,
get control of your shadow self. Your shadow self
is..." And the more I think about it, and the more
I've gone through my journeys and all my kind of
evolutions, I'm realizing that most of the time,
you are the shadow self. You. It's you —
Tim Ferriss: The primary actor.
Soman Chainani: — you are the problem. The better
version of yourself is actually out there. Your
double. Right? And so, I think you have to flip
it, and at any given moment, and it's a good
exercise to do all day long, just a mental thought
experiment, of what if I'm the shadow and there's
a better version of myself, completely independent
human outside that door that could take over this
life and completely handle it with no issues.
And so, it's been something that, if you look
at all my fiction, all my fiction is about
some version of twins, one good, one evil,
one this, one that. And it's always — I think it's
that. It's that I'm always trying to figure out,
am I who I'm supposed to be? And I
think often psychology will say, "Well,
you have to get control of that shadow."
And sometimes I'm like, "Well, no. Maybe
I just need to not be here and let the double
be in charge." And so, I think it's something
I'll be exploring in everything I do, because I
think it's such an important concept that we've
reversed it and that we shouldn't be afraid of
the shadow, because the shadow is actually —
Tim Ferriss: Staring right back at us.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So when does this thought, this
concept, come up for you? I have a friend who's
calm in almost all circumstances, certainly
compared to me, Matt Mullenweg. And there
have been times when I have thought to myself,
"What would Matt Mullenweg do?" Almost like a
reminder bracelet that some people have for
JC and so on. And that has been very helpful.
When I'm in a situation, I feel myself on the
verge of becoming dysregulated. Not like "Hulk
smash," but just having some type of rumination or
tantrum internally that is not helpful. I'm like,
"Pause. What would Matt Mullenweg do?" And I'm
like, "You know how he would handle this is he
would do da da da." And then, sometimes I just
do that thing and I'm like, "Well, that wasn't
so hard." So I'm curious if there are times
when you feel your lesser self doing something,
or I guess in this case, your shadow,
right, doing something where you're like,
"What would my double do?" How does it come up?
Soman Chainani: It came up first because I was
going to be on The Kelly Clarkson Show two years
ago, and I had never been on kind of a TV show
like that. And it was live studio audience.
It was straight out of COVID. And I was like,
"I'm just — I'm not ready for it.
I just don't know how to do this."
Tim Ferriss: Did you decide to do
that or that came suggested to you?
Soman Chainani: Yeah. Yeah. So, the publicist was
like, "We booked you on Kelly." And I was like, "I
don't know." Especially after lockdown, and I was
just not ready for, I think one of the first shows
that she had people back. And I remember in the
dressing rooms starting to freak out and panic,
and I could feel that panic rising. And then, all
of a sudden, I felt this counterforce where I was
stressing on my phone. I felt myself put the phone
down and I just felt some other presence be like,
"It's fine. We've got this." And I almost remember
in that moment being like, "Okay." I just felt it.
And that was the first time I'd ever felt
something like that. Because I remember
sitting on the couch and feeling totally chill.
David Duchovny was next to me. I had grown up
watching X-Files. I made a sex joke with him in
the first two seconds of the thing. I was just
totally chill. And I just was like, "What?"
I'm literally watching myself being like,
"What is happening?" And that was the first
time I got a sense of like, "Oh, wait…"
Tim Ferriss: The possibility.
Soman Chainani: That there's a better version that
can handle every situation. And I remember the
other thing that gave me a clue was Tiger Woods.
There was a documentary about Tiger Woods on HBO,
and they talked about how his dad taught him kind
of techniques to almost hypnotize himself when he
played so that his conscious mind wasn't working
and that's how he dominated all those years. And
I thought, that's it. It's almost like you have to
get your conscious brain out of the way because
the double, the real version of yourself that
knows how to do everything, is there somewhere.
And the question is, over time, can you make it
so they start to integrate? And then, a useful
thing that also helped me start to explore it was
I started doing IFS. Do you know this? Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Internal Family Systems. Yeah,
I've had the founder Dick Schwartz on the podcast.
Soman Chainani: Oh, no way. So I started doing
IFS therapy, exploring those parts, and that's
when you really start to be able to see them in
practice and work with them and start to feel more
comfortable letting go. I think IFS was — I think
the ketamine treatments plus IFS —
Tim Ferriss: Plus Kelly Clarkson.
Soman Chainani: — plus that Kelly Clarkson moment
was sort of the secret I think about a few years
ago where everything sort of came together.
Personally, do you have thoughts for how you're
going to explore that or implement it?
Soman Chainani: I think it comes really,
it's in therapy and it's in those ketamine
treatments where I think sometimes what I'll
do now is if I go in for a booster
or if I go in for IFS, I just think,
"Okay. I'm taking myself out of this. Let's see
what comes from the other part of myself." You
know what I mean? The part that is the
creative force is the one that has the
vision of where I should be going next. The one
who knows what next book I should be writing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, light unbidden.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. I would like to have a
better connection to the thing that is running my
life, which is why we should talk about QBs next.
Tim Ferriss: QBs. QBs. Is this quarterbacks?
Soman Chainani: It is. And this is so funny.
The most spiritual revelations I've ever
had watching a TV show have come watching
that Netflix series Quarterback.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I haven't seen
it. I've only heard of it.
Soman Chainani: It's amazing.
It follows Patrick Mahomes, Kirk Cousins,
and Marcus Mariota for the 2022 season.
Tim Ferriss: I feel like I know you pretty
well. How did you end up watching Quarterbacks?
Soman Chainani: Taylor started dating
Travis, then I felt like, "Okay."
Tim Ferriss: T. Swift is another part.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, we'll get there. So,
it felt like — okay. I grew up watching a
lot of Dolphins games and I actually love
football. I could watch football all day long.
I just never really got into it because I didn't
have a reason. You know what I mean? There was
no team I was rooting for. And the Dolphins
always sucked for a long time. So Taylor gave me
more reason, and so I just watched it, because
I'd also been hearing good things, and I love
sports talks. I just feel like it's the closest
thing I can feel to high-performance stress.
Tim Ferriss: You've played a lot of tennis,
also, for people who don't have the background.
Soman Chainani: So I start watching it and I
realize that this position of being a quarterback
is the greatest metaphor for what life should be
because we all think we're the decision makers as
what we were talking about with follow the flow.
We think we're the ones in charge of everything
like that. That's not what a quarterback is. The
quarterback knows all the possible plays. The
other forces are calling it into his helmet.
He's not even able to talk to the coach. He can't
talk back to the coach. It's a one-way system. So
literally, it's the universe telling him what the
play is. So he's hearing, "White squall, Madonna,
six, wing," whatever. He's like, "Okay. Execute."
Right? So that's it. And I feel like that's what
life should be. You're in the flow so much that
the orders are coming from outside. Orders are
coming from outside telling you what the play is.
You get the play. You go into the huddle. You
communicate the play to your whole team. Now,
everybody's on the same page as you. You've
got everyone with you now. You go into
the huddle, the ball is snapped to you,
and now you have to adjust, because the world's
going to react to your play. And that's where
it gets interesting because you have to be so
present and in the moment that you can react to
what's going to happen. And to me, that's life.
Everyone's focused so much on deciding the play.
Don't focus on deciding the play. Once you feel
a play, execute it, just go, follow it. And if it
busts, whatever. You've got a new play coming.
And so, each of them had such a great — each
of them is so different. Mahomes is just sort of a
physical freak of nature and so smart and able to,
on the fly, improvise. And so, he's
very kind of — I think of him as almost
pliable. He's very spongy. He can sort
of move and adjust at the last minute,
and he's so sort of confident in that ability.
Kirk Cousins is more like me where he's not
particularly physically adept, but he's brainy
and nerdy. And so, where the other quarterbacks
are in the gym doing all their physical training,
he's at biofeedback sessions, because he feels
like if he can get his brain to just be calm,
the calmest in the most stressful situations,
it'll tell him what to do. Roger Federer was
similar. He said that every tennis player
tenses up as they're about to hit the ball because
the pressure of hitting the right shot gets them
at the last nanosecond. And his job is to stay
relaxed so he has an extra millisecond of options.
And so, it was just something about that show
where I was like, "These guys are learning to
not be — they don't call the play, but
they're the executing guys." And I just
think that's life. Let the plays come to you.
Let them come through your invisible headset.
Don't question it. You can't talk back to it.
Just take the play, and then execute. So there
was something about that show. I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: I've got to check it out. I've got
to check it out.
Soman Chainani:
It did something to me at a deep level.
Tim Ferriss: All right. We're going to jump
straight to T. Swift because knowing very little
about Taylor Swift, but watching, what was it
called, Americana, I want to say, the documentary.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. Miss Americana.
Tim Ferriss: I have a fascination in the
phenomenon of Taylor Swift and the rerecording and
the masters. Some of these fascinating decisions
with incredible outcomes. I'm very interested,
but I know very little. But I do recall when the
whole football cameo came into Taylor's life,
somebody who is more attuned to all of these
pop phenomena said millions of people, Swifties,
are about to become very interested in football.
And that's going to be a curious development.
Where does that lead? Okay. So, T. Swift —
Soman Chainani: It's funny. I grew up idolizing
Madonna and I think one of the reasons
I was so interested in Madonna was some
part of me was kind of pre-adapting
her central question of existence
to what was going to be my life, which is —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I need you to unpack that.
Soman Chainani: — you're like, "How is
this sentence going to end?" Which is,
as an artist, how do you sustain a career
for a long period of time without it just
being a downward diminishing returns? And what I
loved about Madonna was that reinvention and the
ability to completely reinvent herself.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Brilliant. Brilliant
at doing it.
Soman Chainani: And she did it
for so long. And then now she's in her close to 70
and in her legacy celebration era. She's done, in
terms of that part. It's funny because Taylor in a
lot of ways follows the same script, which is each
album is a reinvention. To the point of now when
she is on tour, it's the Eras Tour. It's this idea
that "You're going to embrace all the different
parts of me, but they're all very different and
they go in different directions. And that's part
of my identity now. So do not expect me to stay
in the box for the next thing, because that's not
what is happening. And that's not what you want."
So, I think it's why when I went to write fairy
tales, I think the fact that I am such a — also,
the reason it's in the absurd column is because
I've liked her for so long. And now, I'm so used
to comparing myself to her when she wasn't even,
comparing, not myself, but her moves and things,
that now that she's so popular, it's almost
more ridiculous when I tell people, well,
we did both move to Missouri for 6'5"
aggressively masculine, athletic men.
So I do feel like a special kinship.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe your
light — maybe your double is Taylor Swift.
Soman Chainani: I wondered about that. I had — one
of the ketamine treatments was about this.
Tim Ferriss: She's like, "I got you,
babe." For the Kelly Clarkson, she's
like, "We've done this a million times."
Soman Chainani: That would be pretty awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Breathe.
Soman Chainani: Can she deposit some
of the funds instead of hoarding?
But it is this idea of how do you make it so
not staying in the box is your thing? Because
that was Madonna's thing, and that's what I
want mine to be. And that's why aggressively,
I can't be afraid of this next thing when
I'm going out with something so different.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so excited for you. This was —
not comparing myself to Taylor Swift, nor to you,
different circumstances, different time in life.
But after The 4-Hour Workweek, every pressure,
including a lot of internal pressure, but every
expectation and pressure was that I was going
to do something in the same category, something
with the same brand, which I did obliquely. But
The 4-Hour Workweek for fill-in-the-blank, kind
of franchise the whole thing, fine splice it,
milk it for all it's worth, do The 3-Hour
Workweek, whatever it might be. But at that point,
and you certainly have this optionality, I pause
because the inclination was to rush. And whenever
that is the pressure, I tend to hit the brakes.
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm like, "Wait a second." This
has bought me permission to write another book.
This is the time when people are going to be
willing to take a gamble because this first
one went so bananas. I can always go back
to The 4-Hour Workweek. Right? That door
does not close or it doesn't get locked, at
least. Similarly, if you try this new thing,
you'll be welcomed back with open arms.
Soman Chainani: It's Julia Roberts
with her long, red hair.
Tim Ferriss: That's right.
Soman Chainani: I'm here to
write more fairy tales for you.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. And that's when I went to
The 4-Hour Body, totally different category. A
lot of people assumed, within publishing, totally
different readership. But I was like, "If this
works, if this works, it's not guaranteed to work,
but if it works, then I buy myself permission to
do things that are not within this category."
Soman Chainani: 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: And I can always go back. I have
the optionality of hitting control Z in a sense,
hitting undo, and going back to what I was doing.
Soman Chainani: But I also think that what was
interesting about The 4-Hour Body is it just
seems so — it's so funny because that anyone
would question that, it just seems so
obvious, because you had presented a
hack of the work life. So, then for you to
be like, "I'm now presenting a hack of your
physical existence," of course. Nothing about it
seemed — did you feel like, "This is obvious?"
Tim Ferriss: I did.
Soman Chainani: You
did. That's the important thing.
Tim Ferriss: I did. Including some
of my close friends, like Matt Mullenweg who
I mentioned. He was like, "Yeah. Of course."
Soman Chainani: Of course.
Tim Ferriss: Because he knew that
for all the notes and analysis and so on that I'd
put together interviews I conducted for business,
I had, he knew, and there's no reason why
my publishers would know this, although I
did tell them — and to their credit, they were
willing to go with The 4-Hour Body, which then
took off and became very successful. But he knew
that I had basically all of my workouts recorded
since age 16. He knew the extent to which I
had captured data and experimented on myself.
And to him, he's very productive. And in Silicon
Valley, he's like, "Yeah. The productivity stuff,
that's great." He's like — but for his peer group,
he's like, "They're all incredibly good at that.
They're all incredibly good at maximizing per hour
output." He said, "What we're not good at and what
we want from you is actually more of the physical
stuff." So, all of them personally we're asking
me questions about the exercise side. And I was
like, "Okay. The same lens, the same framework,
the same principles, they can be applied here."
Soman Chainani: That's so interesting
because it's what's so obvious. Right? What are
people asking you? What do people
ask me? "How do I fix my teenager?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Soman Chainani: Okay. So, that's
what I'm going to write about.
Tim Ferriss: What's just staring you in the face?
Soman Chainani: What's staring you in the face?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. What is just staring you in the
face? All right. Should we go to another person?
Soman Chainani: Sure. I'm really interested in
these two authors who, I just feel like
we're in the age of hyper productivity,
the rush of content. Right? So, you have to
put out a book every year. You have to put out
content on Instagram all the time, this ubiquity
of — and I find that the people that, especially
the authors that we most hold onto, and the ones
that we start to get obsessed over, and in a weird
ironic way are the most popular on TikTok, are
the ones who release a book every eight years. So,
thinking of Donna Tartt as one author and the
other one that sort of goes together with her,
her name is Hanya and the last name is Yanagihara.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Soman Chainani: And Donna Tartt wrote Goldfinch,
Secret History. She's only written three books.
She writes one every 10 years, and she's due
for exactly 10 years. So she did one at 29,
39, 49, and her 59th birthday just passed. So, we
should be seeing one any moment. And then Hanya
wrote A Little Life, which —
Tim Ferriss: A Little Life.
Soman Chainani: — yes. Which I read —
Tim Ferriss: Yanagihara.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. She's the editor of the
T Magazine for New York Times. And she wrote
this book that is the most immersive, committed —
that's what her and Donna do. They spend years and
years writing their books and they become these
immersive, complete experiences to the point of
they just consume you because they're so real. And
what I find so interesting is Donna Tartt, there's
a whole section of TikTok dedicated to her. A
Little Life, 10 years later, selling, it's number
20 on Amazon, TikTok's obsessed with it. And it's
because of the level of commitment of the work.
And that's I think what I aspire to deep down, is
to be able to just be so committed to something
that you're able to have the time and freedom
to spend a very long time on it, so that you
can really create this alternate thing that is
undeniable. It will exist forever because it's
that committed. And so, those two authors, I think
are a sign that no matter how addled, or stupid,
or short-term thinking, or monkey meme, we get,
it doesn't matter. That stuff still holds because
they're the two most popular authors on TikTok.
Tim Ferriss: Why do you think they are? And I
know that you just explained part of the picture
in your mind, why they are so popular on TikTok,
because there are many dedicated authors,
let's just take as a category of profession,
who release books infrequently, who are supremely
good at the craft, who are not popular on TikTok.
So what do you think it is about these two, even
if you had to just make stuff up, speculating,
what do you think it is about these two
in particular? What else adds to that?
Soman Chainani: It goes with
this one. So, this is together.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Levels of feeling.
Soman Chainani: Which is together with Sally
Rooney, who's another author who I'm obsessed
with, these three authors are able to access a
certain kind of primal nerve of feeling because
they're so immersed in it, they're just there
that it's the intensity of reading it just
feels higher than anything else. Like yes,
you can have someone who spent 10 years crafting
this meticulous world and all that sort of stuff,
I've read plenty of books like that, but there's
something about the 10 years that is spent doing
that work we talked about, what does the character
want? Why do they want it? Why do they want that?
Why do they want that? And they do it for every
character so that when you're reading it, you're
just in this emotional soup that is undeniable.
It's just so affecting to everybody who reads it.
So there's this category of book that I can
recommend to anybody who comes to me and says,
"What book should I read?" I always tell them
Secret History by Donna Tartt, A Little Life
by Hanya, Conversations with Friends
by Sally Rooney. Those are my first
three recommendations. And it doesn't matter,
man, woman, young, old, it always works out.
Tim Ferriss: I have not read any of those three.
Soman Chainani: Well, which one
should you start with?
Tim Ferriss: That's the
question, which one should I start with and why?
Soman Chainani: Oh, boy, they're all so different.
It depends on their mood. A Little Life —
Tim Ferriss: Well,
you can interrogate my mood then.
Soman Chainani: A Little Life is if you are
in the mood to be kind of torn apart.
Tim Ferriss: Not right now.
Soman Chainani: Yeah. So then I would wait for
that one. That one, it's almost like a hijack.
Tim Ferriss: I'm open to that.
Soman Chainani: Yeah,
it's an emotional hijack. You will disappear.
Tim Ferriss: I'm open to that, just not right now.
Soman Chainani: Conversations with Friends is the
most accurate depiction of what it's like to be,
I don't know this for sure, but I just mean
what I think of what it means to sort of be
in a feminine state of mind in your 20s. It is
just crystal clear and brilliant writing of the
emotions of what it's like to be young. And so
I just think for anyone who has ever been young,
when you read it, it takes you back there. It
takes over everything. So I think that one,
and you'll tear through it in a day and
a half because you won't be able to stop.
Secret History is if you just want great writing
and feel like you're in a different world,
because Donna takes her 10 years to meticulously
create a world that the characters feel so real
that you're there. So if you're just ready to
go somewhere else and disappear for a while,
but without the emotional hijacking, you go to
Donna Tartt. If you want to be emotionally thrown
into a well, Hanya, and if you just want the
equivalent of a Taylor Swift album in prose that
is much more articulate, you go to Sally Rooney.
Tim Ferriss: Conversations with Friends. Perfect,
all right. Where should we go next? Now, I'm
enjoying this game because as we flip these over,
we get to fewer and fewer options.
Soman Chainani: These three —
Tim Ferriss: Interrelated?
Soman Chainani: Are going to all go together.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so we've got two yellows,
which are changed mind about, "Cross-collar
dating," not sure what that is, "Hookups,"
suspect I know what that is, "Couples language."
Soman Chainani: Maybe we should start with
cross-collar dating then, because that's sort of
the unlocking key. Have you never heard this term?
Tim Ferriss: I've never heard this term. I know
what a cross-collar throw is in judo, but I'm
guessing this is unrelated. Cross-collar dating.
Is that like white collar, blue collar?
Soman Chainani: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just guessing.
Soman Chainani: Yes, yes, yes,
it. And it's been popular now, I've just seen
there are a lot of columns about this and things
like that, which is also why when I thought when
Taylor started dating Travis, I'm like, "They're
going to last forever," because they just will.
Now watch, I'll have to eat my words. But it's
similar to what happened to me, which was I lived
in New York for 22 years. I dated every lawyer,
accountant, investment banker out there, I went
through it all and it always felt like two clouds
in the sky and no one on Earth — we were doing
jobs that a monkey would not understand. Could
you explain your job to a monkey? Neither of us,
like, "Oh, I write..." It wasn't going to work.
So then when I met [redacted], who literally is
just in the Earth, he can tell you when it's going
to rain. It felt like it was just such a match
of someone who has Earth energy and someone who
has sky energy. Because in Hinduism, that's the
balance. It's not masculine/feminine, it's not
male/female, it's sky energy and Earth energy.
Tim Ferriss: I'm ashamed and astonished,
I've never heard this before.
Soman Chainani: So that's the balance
you're looking for. And I'm all sky, I'm all what
they call Shakti, which is thunder and lightning,
that's me. So I need somebody who's the guy on
the ground holding the kite before it flies on.
And so I just think of, what was I doing? I
should have known from the start. And I think
I started to sense it this time around that I
needed to be with someone ultra grounded. And
so that's why I think cross-collar dating works
because also you're not in each other's space,
there's no competition. You're not competing
for the same thing. You're not measuring each
other against each other.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe you also
have different neuroses.
Soman Chainani: That's it.
Tim Ferriss: Which is probably good.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, he's thinking about,
every one of [redacted] neuroses is about, does he
have enough money to sell this group of calves for
that? And I'm like, "I'm sure it's fine." That's
my reaction to everything, "I'm sure it's fine,"
but I can't relate other than be supportive.
And when he comes to watch me do the dance in
Charleston, he's just like, "This is a lot."
Tim Ferriss: Not sure what this is,
but you do you.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent. He
calls it the dance of the red shoes, as a metaphor
in general. He's like, "He's off doing his dance
of the red shoes. We'll see him when he's done,"
and that could be anything. So I think that's what
it is. And whenever I see two lawyers together,
I'm like, "Oh, no, who's going to...?" I don't
know. So yeah, something worth looking at.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Today I learned
cross-collar dating. And now well actually,
look, I'll ask a self-serving question so I'm
back on the singles field, as you know, we've
talked about this privately. So what would
that potentially mean for me? Is it more a set
of characteristics? Is it profession? I mean,
I have definitely, this is not exactly the same,
but I have had enough perhaps tiptoeing around
this to realize probably not a good idea for me
to be with another writer, you know what I mean?
Soman Chainani: Agreed.
Tim Ferriss: I've taken
that parking spot. I think that one is enough.
Soman Chainani: Agreed. I think it's as simple as,
it's not so much the caller, it's about the
intensity of the commitment to what it is.
So for instance, I'm so committed to my writing
career and the entrepreneurship of my life that it
is such a huge part of what I do that you want to
find somebody who has that same commitment to what
they do that is in a completely different space.
So that's why I look at Taylor and Travis Kelce,
because she's the most famous pop star in the
world, she's always in the number one position.
What man is ever going to be able to have that
same level intensity but a football player playing
in the same stadium in front of the same amount of
people, and she has to be there rooting for them.
Tim Ferriss: It's perfect.
Soman Chainani: It's like you're
each doing your thing, it's yours. It's not the
other person's, but the other person is there to
cheerlead. And I think that to me is the perfect
recipe of where — and I think sometimes when you
have, even if it's an investment banker and
a lawyer, they're similar, there's something
similar about it. But if you can find something
that's really different so that you can just
relax and be a cheerleader and feel almost humble,
like [redacted] coaches basketball and when I go
watch the games, it's just fun to watch him coach
basketball because that has nothing to do with my
existence. I have nothing to do with it.
Tim Ferriss: I didn't know that part,
you must love that. I'm just
thinking of you with the tutoring
and also tennis background. You must love it.
Soman Chainani: And he comes to me with all his,
"This kid this. What do I say to this kid,
this?" And I'm just always asking him questions,
I love it. It's my favorite thing. I'm always
asking him more questions about what's happening
with the drama behind the scenes.
Tim Ferriss: I'm still thinking of
the dance of the red shoes. I may use
that with you, that's great. All right,
where should we go? Hookups or couples language?
Soman Chainani: Well, couples language is a really
quick one, but I think it's really interesting
that with couples, I feel like every couple —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, this is in the
absurd category, just so people know.
Soman Chainani: Because I thought it was just
us, we have our own language at times, words we
make up and things that we have that no one else
would understand. And it's almost like animals,
we just came up with our own little barks
and things and repeated phrases and repeated
thoughts that are just ours. And then I talked
to other couples and they have it too. And I
was talking to a friend about this where he's
like, him and his partner used to, instead of
saying the word "program," they used to use
a British accent for it and say "program" or
something. And that was how they always said it.
And then they broke up and then the new partner
heard about this somehow and started using it
and he felt this irrational sense of anger.
Tim Ferriss: Like aversion to it, yeah.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, because it's somebody
else's language. That's when I thought, "Oh, no,
this is a real thing. This is somehow in our DNA
to create this private language with our other
person." [redacted] and I have a million of them,
but we use the word "malinky" a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Malinkey?
Soman Chainani: Malinkey to refer to something
that is on its way to being totally fucked,
but has not gotten there. It's circling the drain.
Tim Ferriss: Is this an adjective or a
noun? It is a malinky or it is —
Soman Chainani: No, it is malinky,
it's an adjective. So we use that a lot. A
person could be malinky, a dish that we're
trying to cook could be malinky. So it just
comes up. And so we have maybe a hundred of
these kind of words. And so nicknames and things,
and so it's just our own little private language.
Tim Ferriss: Hookups.
Soman Chainani: This is a pretty simple one, but
in New York, hookup culture was big and I never
really got into it. I always was more interested
in connections and things like that. And people
are like, "But it's fun, so many hot guys," I
mean, New York, Austin is similar, everywhere you
go, everyone's like a supermodel, it's annoying.
But the reason that it stopped me was every time
I was like, "Okay, you could go hook up with that
guy, whatever." I used to think to myself, "Well,
what's the reason?" And I realized that it was
because I was trying to extract something from
them. They had this hotness or this thing or this
thing that I felt that by hooking up with them,
I would get, right? And that's when I started
thinking about the term hookup. What is it?
Hook? It's like you're trying to literally like
a fish hook them and get this thing. There's no
connection needed, you're going to dispose of them
at some point, you know it's not going to last.
Tim Ferriss: You're just going to lean over,
breathe in their soul.
Soman Chainani: That's
it. And I thought to myself —
Tim Ferriss: Sell their chi.
Soman Chainani: And in my case, it was obvious
because it felt like I was going after certain
kind of guys that had things that I wanted. And I
realized that it was never because I liked them,
it was because I wanted to be them or I wanted
this thing that they had physically or something.
And it was always like, you just want to extract.
And I thought, "That can't be good for your soul."
I just thought that can't be good because what's
going to happen if you mentally go through with
it? Yes, you're going to go, you're going to
extract this thing or try to extract it, you're
going to fail to extract it and they're going
to leave and you're still not going to have it.
Tim Ferriss: I think New York, as you
described it, is just such a hyperkinetic
environment that I feel like whether it's
related to hookups or alcohol or other,
you need to have some guardrails or I feel like
that environment will sort of eat you alive.
Soman Chainani: I think it's funny because
we can move to that one now that we're here,
I lived there for 22 years and I would go to
Florida and go to places that were much slower
to relax. But I think with New York and L.A.
what I realized is until you're out of there
for an extended period of time, that's when
you finally get to be yourself. Because New
York and L.A. and even Chicago and the biggest
city, San Francisco, everything's so reactive.
It's too much stimulus to ever process in a way
where you're just alone with your thoughts in a
consistent way. So it's not just vacation, but on
a permanent basis. And when I moved to St. Louis,
I didn't have any friends there, I was new to the
city, I knew no one, still getting used to it,
but it's quiet, not much is happening. And for
the first time in my life, it was just me. And
I felt like in those 10 months I had to grow.
Tim Ferriss: I got it. So you had a 10-month
period where you were there full time?
Soman Chainani: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Because I was going to say,
the astute listener may note that you said I go
every weekend earlier, I think that was right.
Soman Chainani: To St. Louis?
Tim Ferriss: You tell me,
what is your geographic split?
Soman Chainani: Okay, so I moved to St. Louis
in end of January of this year. And then I go
to New York maybe three or four days a
month. And in those three or four days
when I first started going, I felt like, "I'm
home, thank God." And then each time I went,
I started to dread it and dread it more. I was
still seeing all my friends, I was getting to
do all the fun stuff that I get to do in New
York whenever I go there, the restaurants,
the this. But I was just like, I could feel myself
be like, "We're going to war." That's what it
feels like when you go into the city again.
And I just realized, especially for me,
where I'm at my stage where I want to commit to
my art and the things I want to do and connection
and relationships, especially with this new
set of tools that I have post ketamine where
I feel like I'm finally getting to connect and
be in the moment and have fun and be present
and slow in terms of my experiences, in
New York, it never would've happened.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think you'll have an ebb
and flow in that way, you'll have a seasonal
relationship to that stuff? Do you think there's
a chance that you do St. Louis for a period and
then you have sort of a city period and
then a rural period? Or do you think —
Soman Chainani: I think what I'm realizing is
I'm in the creative zone now where I'm done
with School for Good and Evil and fairy tales for
a while, I'm making new work. So for the next two
years, that's really where I am, is the making
new work, which involves also making new life,
new partner, new city. It's a new chapter totally.
It's a second act, right? It looks nothing like my
first act, first act was New York fairy tales,
I'm now doing something totally different in St.
Louis and I'm on a goat farm. So new album,
right? So I don't know what will happen when
I'm done writing and it's time to promote.
Will it be dance of the red shoes again,
let's go to New York and dress up?
Tim Ferriss: Of course it will be.
Soman Chainani: Of course it will be. I
think it'll be great. I think it'll be great.
Tim Ferriss: You see, you have a goat
farm. Goat farm, St. Louis. What is St.
Louis like? I haven't spent any time there.
Soman Chainani: It's quiet, it's manageable.
It's a very family-oriented city. Whenever people
are like, "Oh, I just moved to St. Louis," it's
to be near family usually, most of the time.
Tim Ferriss: I just feel like, you're not in
the outer reaches of the Brooks Range in
Alaska, like a flight from people, you
have access to restaurants and things like that.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, yeah. Everything's there,
restaurants are there. I just think it's a
city that has a lot of potential. It reminds
me a little bit of when I first started to come to
Austin eight or nine years ago, I was like, "Oh,
this place is going to go crazy one day when
people find out what's here." St. Louis isn't
quite at that level. I feel like it's evolving,
but there's a lot there where people are going
to be like, weather's good, people are great,
food's good, easy to get around, no traffic.
It just feels like it's a sleepy little city
that people kind of gave up on but I wouldn't
be surprised if it has a boom at some point.
Tim Ferriss: It's the opposite of a malinky.
Soman Chainani: It's opposite of a malinky.
Tim Ferriss: Or it is opposite of malinky,
excuse me, I used it incorrectly.
Soman Chainani: It's opposite. Yeah, no, there's
a lot to be said about St. Louis. And
also I just haven't met that many people,
so I'm excited to start making friends.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking of Britishisms,
when you're mentioning the shared language of
program, I have no idea, dodgy, dodgy allergies.
This is in the absurd category on purple cards.
Soman Chainani: This is a good one to end on.
I tell everyone I'm allergic to
cranberries and eggplant. Am I
allergic to cranberries and eggplant?
Tim Ferriss: Are you? I don't know.
Soman Chainani: I don't know. But I've been
saying it for so long that I am like, is it
true? So the question is when we are allergic
to things, and I think this gets to a bigger,
more profound question, where did that start? I
know that once upon a time I thought cranberries
caused hives or something, and then I ate
cranberries, I don't know, this was probably
when I was a teenager and got a bad case of
hives and therefore have told people ever since,
"I can't eat cranberries." But was it because —
Tim Ferriss: It could be something else.
Soman Chainani: It could be something else, right?
And so this happens, I think, a lot with when we
were young, I remember first having peanut
butter and things like that and having weird
reactions to it being like, "This makes me feel
weird." But there was no option to stop eating
it. There was no, "Don't eat the peanut butter."
It was like, "We'll just keep giving you peanut
butter until one day your system gets used to
it." So I was just thinking about the fact that
the way that it's easy to, in your mind, create
these little zones of, "I can't touch eggplant."
Tim Ferriss: No-fly zones.
Soman Chainani: Once upon a time this
thing happened and it makes you start to question,
I don't know, deeper, no-fly zones. So anyway,
that was something that crossed my mind of at some
point we need to test the no-fly zones, basically
eat cranberry sauce and see what happens.
Tim Ferriss: So small world, for the record,
if you're working in a restaurant, I
tell you I have an eggplant allergy,
it's because I ate eggplant my whole life, and
then one day, boom, anaphylaxis, full-blown,
like almost died in a restaurant.
Soman Chainani: Is that true?
Tim Ferriss: In San Francisco. It's true.
And I went in, that wasn't step one,
step one was had this dish, had some whatever
it was, swordfish, fine, vegetables, fine,
outside of eggplant. Then I had the eggplant and
my tongue got really itchy and I was like, "Huh,
that's weird. It feels like an allergic reaction.
I've never had an allergic reaction to eggplant."
So being the genius that I am, and I'm saying
that sarcastically, I was like, "Well, I'm going
to purchase like an engineer. I want to figure
out, can I replicate the bug?" So I went back the
next day, pro-tip, do not do this. If you have a
mild allergic reaction, don't do what I'm about to
describe. So I went back and I was like, "Well,
I'll try it again, and if my tongue gets itchy,
I'll go have a slew of testing." But that's not
how allergic reactions work. If you have one
allergic reaction that is minor, it can suddenly
step function up to something very serious.
And that's exactly what happened. So I ate the
exact same dish, I had the allergic reaction,
but this time my throat closed down to the
size of a coffee straw. And it was rush hour,
it was in the Mission, certain part of the Mission
in San Francisco where there was absolutely no
possibility that an ambulance was going to get
to me within 30 minutes, no bodega or anything
nearby. I asked the staff, I was like, "Do you
have any Benadryl?" And they're like, "No." "Do
you have an EpiPen?" "No." And I was like, "Fuck."
Of all the dumb things that I've done in my life,
this is what's going to kill me, really? And I
just sat there. That was all I could do. And I
was like, "Well, freaking out isn't going to do
anything," and I was like, "I guess I'm just going
to have to try to breathe very calmly."
Soman Chainani: And slowly.
Tim Ferriss: And I passed through it, and
therefore I have not had much eggplant. Now I will
say I went and had extensive, extensive allergy
testing done at Stanford with all these top docs,
and at least with the species of eggplant that
they used for their various sampling and testing,
no demonstrable allergy to eggplant,
which raises a bunch of questions. Now,
one option is it's a different species of
eggplant, okay, possibly, who knows? The other,
which is scarier, which a very well-known
friend and tech founder who people would
recognize brought up, was maybe it is a
pesticide that you are unable to identify.
Soman Chainani: Oh, shoot.
Tim Ferriss: But that is so
psychologically terrifying —
Soman Chainani: Yes, yes,
yes, because anything can happen.
Tim Ferriss: For me to contemplate
that I've doubled down on the eggplant.
Soman Chainani: See, and this is why
dodgy allergies came to my mind,
because it's like the fundamental —
Tim Ferriss: At least I can avoid eggplant.
Soman Chainani: Right. To me, when I say dodgy,
what I mean is mental allergies in the sense
of the allergy is compounded sometimes by
this extra force. So when I was on
a plane and they called out, "Okay,
someone has a peanut allergy, therefore, we're not
serving peanuts or cashews," or whatever it was,
everyone was like, "Oh, okay," a little
grumbling, but whatever. Next plane,
they were like, "Someone has an alcohol allergy,
we are not serving alcohol," it was like Saigon,
like everyone —
Tim Ferriss: Mutiny.
Soman Chainani: Everyone's racing for the last
helicopter, do you know what I mean? To get off
that plane. So it was a sudden thing of, "Okay,
we have to take the allergy seriously, but then
this one we're not taking seriously," because it
just comes to me sometimes when I think it's worth
looking at the mental stress around the allergy.
Tim Ferriss: I agree. And also just asking the
30,000-foot question, which I'm sure very
competent, qualified people have examined,
but what is going on with all of these allergies?
Soman Chainani: Well, that was the question.
That's what I was thinking to myself, when I was
young, I definitely think I had a peanut allergy
and it just, I think, got used to the discomfort
and to the point where the body was finally like,
"All right, I guess we're doing this," and just
I guess got used to it. And I don't think that
was necessarily the right way to handle it,
but that's what happened before and now it's
different. It is interesting to see on the
farm, none of the kids, all the nephews,
nobody has allergies, there's something about
that. The farm just has so much going on that —
Tim Ferriss: Interesting.
Soman Chainani: The first thing
I do with the baby, put her in the cow pen.
Tim Ferriss: Into the farm you go. All right,
there's one more thing I can see over there,
which is one remaining name, I think there's
one remaining maybe, more than one.
Soman Chainani: No, there's one that
is worth talking about, which is the
daughter of a friend who introduced us,
how I first met you. I met you through Brian
Koppelman, the creator of Billions. And I have
an eye completely independent of the fact that
obviously I know her and I've seen her grow up, I
have my eye on his daughter, Anna, who is 23 and a
standup comedian and writer because she's so good.
Tim Ferriss: He has very talented, skilled kids.
Soman Chainani: I tutored both of them.
I did no work with either.
Tim Ferriss: Someone will take
his customer 15 percent.
Soman Chainani: In terms of
working with either of them, there was nothing
to be done. These kids came fully formed.
Tim Ferriss: Babysitting.
Soman Chainani: 100 percent just sat there
and talked to the family and had family dinners
and somehow got paid for it. I felt like they were
the most incredible kids. Sam is the older one and
will probably be president someday, and Anna is
just, she reminds me of, do you know Miranda July?
Tim Ferriss: I do not, great name though.
Soman Chainani: Yeah, she is in the early
2000, late '90s, she is just very prolific and
still writes and great comedy. Just versatile at
everything involving writing and performing. And
that's Anna, I feel like she can write, she can do
standup, she can write novels. It's just the voice
is so sharp and interesting and mature that at 23
that I just am like, "What's going to happen?" So
I feel like she's one to one to —
Tim Ferriss: To keep an eye on?
Soman Chainani: To keep an eye on. I just think
sometimes when I feel like when I was growing up,
people were like, "Okay, we don't know what
he's going to do, but he'll do something
interesting," because I was just kind of off doing
my dance with the red shoes and I feel like Anna,
I feel like the same, something interesting's
going to happen, something interesting is
going to happen. So I have my eye on her.
So it's good to end on somebody young.
Tim Ferriss: Up and comer.
Soman Chainani: Because that's where
I think my brain always is. I'm looking at youth
for talent, ambition, and most of all commitment.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think Brian and
his wife have done to foster some of that?
Soman Chainani: That's a good question.
Tim Ferriss: This could be nature versus nurture,
who knows? Maybe they're just thoroughbreds, came
from good stock, but I suspect there's more to it,
probably a little bit, certainly at
the very least. What do you think?
Soman Chainani: I think they encouraged their
ideas. I just feel like when they had ideas,
it almost felt like an improv house where if one
was like, "I think I should do this," it would be
like, "Yes, and?" Everything was like, "Yes,"
no shooting down ideas. It was just go with
it. Neil deGrasse Tyson talks about how, "To
me, the ideal parent sees a kid reaching for
an egg on the table, like a toddler," and he's
like, "You stop that kid from dropping the egg
because you're afraid of the mess and wasting 40
cents on an egg, you're going to lose that toddler
seeing this thing explode and leak three different
substances and a yolk and a thing and how did that
thing turn into that? And all of a sudden you have
a scientist and a three-year-old. What else can I
drop and see what's going to happen?" And so he's
like, "That's it, it's just saying yes and not
giving too much direction." And that's what I said
about the kid making the bed, the kid coming to
things on his own terms. Don't comment, let them
evolve. Just look at the photo, no need to add
your two cents underneath, you know what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: I do. But fun, this has been so
much fun. Is there anything else you'd like to
mention? Anything you'd like to point people
to? Any closing comments? Anything at all?
Soman Chainani: I think it's just so fun
to get to have a conversation with such a
deep thinker and to be able to play around,
you know what I mean? I never get to do this in
real life. So I feel like getting to do this is an
honor and I'm just very thankful that you had me.
Tim Ferriss: What a pleasure, so fun. I'm looking
forward to continuing at dinner.
Where can people find you online?
Soman Chainani: Best place to find
me is my website, somanchainani.com.
S-O-M-A-N-C-H-A-I-N-A-N-I.com. And
then I don't use Twitter anymore,
so Instagram's probably where I see messages
and things like that. So SomanC on Instagram.
Tim Ferriss: SomanC on Instagram. We'll link to
everything in the show notes, folks so you can
find that at tim.blog/podcast and just search
Soman. There will not be an overwhelming number
of entries, S-O-M-A-N. And until next time,
as always, be a bit kinder than is necessary,
not only to other people, but to yourself. And
thanks for tuning in everybody. Talk to you soon.